[موسيقى]
اخبار عمليه طوفان الاقصى بايجاز من منطقه
غلاف غزه اهلا بكم لليوم الثالث على
التوالي معارك مستمره بين مقاتلي القسام
والجنود الاسرائيليين في عدد من المواقع
داخل غلاف غزه بينها سديروت ونحو 800 قتيل
اسرائيلي وتقديرات بارتفاع العدد وكتائب
القسام تعلن اسرى مجموعه جديده من الجنود
الاسرائيليين
وتخوض اشتباكات عنيفه داخل المستوطنات في
الغلاف غارات اسرائيليه كثيفه على قطاع
غزه جوا وبحرا ترفع اجمالي عدد الضحايا
الى اكثر من
550 شهيدا والاحتلال يقصف سوقا بمخيم
جباليا ما ادى الى استشهاد 50 فلسطينيا
بينما اتهم مسؤول حكومي في غزه اسرائيل
بارتكاب مجازر بحق خم 15 عائله في القطاع
بقصف مباشر
للمنازل كتائب القسام تؤكد قصفها لتل ابيب
والقدس ردا على قصف بيوت المدنيين في قطاع
غزه وتعلن انها وجهت ضربه صاروخيه كبيره
لاسد وعسقلان ب 120 صاروخا واسرائيل تعلن
وقوع اصابات بجروح خطيره في صفوف
الاسرائيليين جراء قصف المقاومه ل عسقلان
وسديت
واسدود بعد الاعلان عن توجيه حامله طائرات
امريكيه الى شرقي المتوسط للتمركز قرب
اسرائيل البيت الابيض يقر حزمه دعم اضافيه
وبايدن يبلغ نتنياهو ان مزيدا من
المساعدات في الطريق وحماس تقول ان اعتزام
امريكا تقديم مساعدات عسكريه اضافيه الى
الاحتلال يمثل مشاركه فعليه بالعدوان على
الشعب الفلسطيني الى
اللقاء